Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
"Le parole sono pietre"
diceva Carlo Levi dalla Sicilia.
E sempre in Sicilia,
la cosiddetta "Ala Cinese"
della Scuola di Palermo del Gruppo 63
considerava le parole delle cose,
delle cose proprio per la loro forma,
per il loro colore, per il loro suono.
Composero anche dei testi narrativi
fatti con le parole
a prescindere dal loro significato,
a dire il vero abbastanza incomprensibili.
Le parole, però, sono anche informazioni.
Le informazioni sono dati.
Il nostro mondo sta cambiando moltissimo.
Voi vedete che ho una pietra,
appunto, in mano.
Il nostro mondo sta cambiando
perché si sta "IoTizzando":
questo è un brutto
neologismo, un anglicismo,
che però ci dice
che ci stiamo riempiendo di cose
in grado di interconnettersi alla rete.
L'"Internet delle Cose",
l'Internet di tutte le cose:
IoT, Internet of Things.
L'Internet delle Cose oggi è il presente,
è qualcosa che tutti conosciamo,
leggiamo da tanto tempo;
però sta per esplodere.
Il 5G farà sì che in pochi anni
arriveremo a - si dice, si prevede -
50 miliardi di oggetti interconnessi.
E questo che cosa significa,
almeno da un punto di vista giuridico?
Significa che inevitabilmente
ci trasformeremo in dati, in informazioni,
anche quando saremo, semplicemente,
presenti fisicamente,
materialmente nel mondo.
Il nostro essere
nel mondo fisico, materiale,
sarà subito anche, e sempre di più,
un essere "datificati",
trasformati in dati.
È come se evaporassimo:
come se, da acqua,
evaporando diventassimo nuvole.
Nessuno può più dire:
"Io non mi registro,
io non fornisco i miei dati
a quest'app, questo sito, questo servizio
e quindi sono sicuro
di non essere catturato
e trasformato in dati".
No.
Evaporeremo, sempre di più.
Ci saranno sensori, sentinelle,
a trasformarci in dati
per il nostro essere presenti fisicamente:
e ce ne saranno sempre di più.
Alcune sentinelle le vedremo,
io alcune le vedo adesso:
vedo le telecamere, vedo il microfono,
lo sento addosso a me.
Ma quante sentinelle potrebbero esserci
in oggetti, in tessuti di ogni tipo?
Sulle poltrone?
Nei cuscini?
Non pensate al frigorifero,
che è la cosa più banale ormai.
Non pensate alla Smart Tv.
Pensate a oggetti ancora
più piccoli, più insignificanti,
in grado di catturarci
e trasformarci in dati.
Poi, in realtà, tutto ciò che "micro",
tutto ciò che è "nano",
potrà sposarsi con l'interconnessione.
E quindi dobbiamo abituarci a pensare
anche a un cosiddetto "BIoT":
l'Internet delle Cose,
delle Biotecnologie,
dei tessuti umani, perché no:
anche un "Internet of Blood",
un Internet del sangue, delle cellule.
Noi stessi saremo, potenzialmente,
pervasi di sentinelle
che ci trasformeranno in dati.
Questo succederà in maniera
abbastanza inconsapevole.
E sarà inconsapevole
proprio perché non sarà facile
accorgersi di questi sensori,
di questi trasformatori,
di questi datificatori.
Ora, catturata questa miriade
di dati che ci riguardano,
catturate le nostre informazioni,
trasformata la nostra presenza in dati
da innumerevoli fonti
estremamente varie, variabili,
questi dati verranno - vengono già,
ma verranno sempre più -
elaborati, processati velocissimamente
con capacità di elaborazione
per volumi straordinari.
È il cosiddetto Big Data.
Naturalmente il Big Data
serve a qualcosa - non solo il Big Data -
ma serve a elaborare, a ragionare,
a essere sempre più intelligenti.
Ma intelligenti chi, cosa?
Gli oggetti.
Comunque, algoritmi non umani.
Immaginate che tutti questi oggetti,
di cui vi parlavo poco fa,
se la facciano e se la dicano,
si scambino informazioni su di noi
e, come è normale
per ogni "Big Data Processing",
ne creano di nuove.
Possono nascere
nuove informazioni altrove,
in oggetti che stanno lontano
e che noi non sospettiamo nemmeno
che stiano elaborando
le nostre informazioni.
Ci sarà sempre di più
qualcuno o qualcosa -
ma anche tanti qualcuno o qualcosa -
che sapranno molte più cose di noi
di quante noi stessi sappiamo.
Questa è una forma di subconscio digitale,
che arriva ad avere
degli effetti sulle nostre vite:
su quello che noi riceviamo,
su quello che riceviamo personalizzato
o comunque come targeting,
perché siamo obiettivi
verso cui presentare dei contenuti.
Allora io vi ho detto
che volenti o nolenti,
inconsapevolmente, come non utenti,
veniamo trasformati:
da acqua che siamo evaporiamo, saliamo
e ci ritroviamo a uno stato gassoso.
Allo stato "gassoso" succedono molte cose,
e ci sono elaborazioni di dati:
dati che ci riguardano,
creazione di nuovi dati.
Ma poi viene a piovere!
Magari non piovono pietre:
però piove acqua,
viene a nevicare, piove grandine.
Cioè si ritrasforma:
quello che per noi è stata
semplicemente una evaporazione,
una trasformazione del nostro essere
nel mondo fisico in dato,
si trasforma in qualcosa di materiale.
Esattamente come un chicco di grandine
che ci arriva in testa.
E questo come può accadere?
Accade perché l'Internet delle Cose
non sarà solo in andata.
Non saranno semplicemente -
e non sono, già oggi -
sensori che ci catturano e ci trasformano.
Ma saranno anche attori, agenti.
Attori, oggetti, cose che interverranno
con azioni materiali,
con effetti materiali
che sono derivati, che sono conseguenza,
di tutto quello che è stato
pensato artificialmente,
con i nostri dati e con altri dati ancora,
lassù, tra le nuvole.
Quindi stiamo attenti.
Non si tratta solo di un'andata:
si tratta del ritorno
dell'effetto materiale.
Una porta che non si apre:
un frigorifero -
per tornare all'esempio banale -
che non si apre, o che si spegne.
Un pacemaker, che funziona o non funziona.
Comunque ha effetti fisici.
Un proiettile che parte
e che magari è stato sparato
a 10.000 km di distanza.
Tutto questo ci deve fare riflettere,
perché la Protezione dei Dati Personali -
che è qualcosa di immateriale:
il dato che cos'è?
È la nostra rappresentazione di sé
verso l'esterno, verso il mondo esterno -
si deve trasformare,
si sta trasformando sempre di più
in Protezione degli Effetti Personali.
In futuro,
anche questa disciplina giuridica
si trasformerà in quella direzione.
Nella Carta dei Diritti Fondamentali
dell'Unione Europea
abbiamo due diversi articoli.
Uno è l'Articolo Sette,
che tutela la sfera privata
e la sfera personale degli individui;
l'altro è l'Articolo Otto,
proprio sulla tutela
dei dati personali, più immateriale.
Dobbiamo ripensare quei due articoli,
quei due macrodiritti,
e rifonderli insieme.
Probabilmente questa è la strada
per riuscire a tutelare veramente
gli effetti personali
in un mondo fortemente IoTizzato.
E probabilmente le tutele previste oggi,
che sembrano guardare al futuro -
tutti voi avrete sentito parlare
mille volte, negli ultimi anni,
di GDPR, di Regolamento Privacy Europeo -
ecco, norme come quelle probabilmente
già mostrano una inadeguatezza,
un'insufficienza per questi scenari.
Pensate solo
che il regolamento europeo, il GDPR,
pensa moltissimo e guarda moltissimo
alle tutele informative:
cioè l'informativa che viene data
prima di iniziare i trattamenti di dati.
Ma, come ci siamo detti,
noi verremo "catturati"
e trasformati in dati,
senza accorgercene.
Gli oggetti non avranno
e non hanno faccia, interfaccia.
Non hanno occhi, bocca, naso
per poter interloquire con noi,
darci l'informativa.
Nove su dieci non funzionano così.
Vedete che già anche quel solo istituto
dell'Informativa Privacy -
che tra l'altro pochissimi leggono -
fa acqua da tutte le parti.
Acqua che potrebbe venire a piovere.
E poi c'è un principio,
nel regolamento europeo,
su cui voglio farvi riflettere:
il principio di "Accountability",
di responsabilizzazione.
Ne hanno parlato tutti i giuristi
che si occupano di queste materie.
Il principio di responsabilizzazione
deve rendere individuabile,
"accountable", responsabilizzato,
ciascun soggetto che decide
determinati trattamenti di dati.
Ma è disegnato
per i soggetti esseri umani.
È disegnato per rendere
accountable, responsabilizzato
l'essere umano, la persona;
o la società, l'organizzazione
che ha comunque un consiglio
d'amministrazione fatto di persone.
Ma se dobbiamo responsabilizzare
gli oggetti, gli oggetti non umani,
come si fa?
Con il GDPR, con la norma europea attuale,
non si fa.
Potrebbero servire tutele
addirittura fisiche
per proteggersi nel futuro IoTizzato,
tutele tridimensionali:
occhiali per non essere riconosciuti
in forma biometrica dalle telecamere,
tecniche di anti radar
portatile personale.
Ora però vi voglio fare riflettere
su un'ulteriore cosa.
Ho una pietra in mano;
ma immaginate che i dati
non siano semplicemente pietre,
che ciò che ne deriva
non sia semplicemente pioggia, neve -
nella metafora che facevo prima -
ma immaginate che siano anche
armi, regole, leggi:
leggi restrittive della libertà personale,
per esempio.
Immaginate che tutto quel mondo di dati,
che verranno sempre più
catturati e creati,
che sarà un mondo di dati
al servizio dell'Intelligenza
Artificiale non umana,
venga utilizzato non semplicemente
per causare effetti nelle piccole cose -
micro regole nelle piccole cose
della vita quotidiana,
che comunque sono importantissime -
ma venga utilizzato
per fare qualcosa di più.
In tutti i Parlamenti,
in quasi tutto il mondo,
per entrare nelle aree legislative
c'è una barriera fisica,
una barriera fisica simbolica.
Se andate anche nel Parlamento Italiano
c'è una riga, alla Camera dei Deputati,
che non può essere superata fisicamente
se non siete gli eletti.
C'è una tutela fisica
del potere legislativo.
Ora immaginate che si consenta,
per regolamento di un Parlamento,
un bel giorno,
la partecipazione da remoto.
I parlamentari sono spesso via,
chiedono di poter partecipare
da remoto alle sedute,
di poter iniziare a votare
anche da remoto.
Chi ci garantisce
che in poco tempo quei voti,
espressi attraverso
quell'identità digitale
di un parlamentare,
o di tanti parlamentari,
perfino della maggioranza,
non si possano in realtà gestire
attraverso l'Intelligenza Artificiale:
attraverso bot, parlamentari bot.
Il primo passo potrebbe essere
proprio quello di farli partecipare
da remoto, i parlamentari veri.
Il secondo o il terzo passo
potrebbe essere quello di avere
una maggioranza di parlamentari -
i voti espressi -
per volontà di un algoritmo,
sempre più esperto,
o di più algoritmi.
Questo è un rischio da scongiurare.
Dal mio punto di vista, è un rischio
di disumanizzazione del potere:
del potere legislativo,
ma naturalmente a tutti i livelli vale.
Nessuna regola dovrebbe essere,
in ultima istanza,
stabilita da un algoritmo.
Se non altro, perché l'IA
tende alla perfezione del calcolo.
L'intelligenza artificiale è una forma -
e sarà sempre più - di iper-razionalità.
Se io voglio un calcolo perfetto,
e devo raggiungere i miei obiettivi,
devo tendere alla iper-razionalità.
Ma l'iper razionalità
è quanto di meno umano,
e quanto di più disumano ci possa essere.
Il nazismo era iper-razionale.
Il compromesso, il perdono,
l'amore, la pace,
sono errori di calcolo.
Noi abbiamo bisogno,
di questi errori di calcolo.
Abbiamo bisogno di conservare
l'elemento umano, nel legislatore,
in tutti i livelli di regolazione.
Il "Super Admin", il comandante in capo,
dovrebbe essere sempre un essere umano;
e questo vale a maggior ragione
per i Parlamenti.
Per questo avrebbe senso inserire,
nelle Costituzioni di singoli Paesi,
o anche a livello
di trattato internazionale,
delle regole nuove.
Lo stato di diritto,
per cui nessuno - neppure un re -
può sentirsi al di sopra della Legge:
è una regola importantissima
che abbiamo in democrazia.
Forse è il caso di aggiornarla:
perché a quel punto potrebbe esserci
la possibilità, per un algoritmo,
di decidere la Legge.
Allora dovremmo aggiornare
lo Stato di Diritto, la Rule of Law.
E parlare non più di Stato di Diritto,
ma di Stato di Diritto Umano:
Rule of Human Law.
L'ultima parola
non dovrebbe mai essere di pietra,
non dovrebbe mai essere di bit:
dovrebbe essere di carne ed ossa,
dovrebbe essere di emozioni
e sentimenti, anche di errori, umani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)